皆さんこんにちは佐藤正樹と申します今日はどうぞよろしくお願い致します
僕は大学卒業後にフリーターなりました
そのとき何を思ったか劇団四季に入りたいという夢を持ちましてそこから5年間猛特訓
を積んで28歳手前で合格しそして入団8年目に主役をやらせイデアのいただいたと
いうちょっと変わったケーキを持っております
20代30代とどうやったら相手に伝わるのかお客様がどうやったら感動してくれるの
か
こういったことを追求して生きてきました皆さんも日々の生活の中でどうやったら自分
の思いが相手に伝わるのかどうやったらお客様に感動が届くのか
こういったことを考えたことがあると思いますしかし多くの方がった
終わるとか感動の部分を感覚として捉えていると思うんですよね
そこで今日は大人から始めてわからないことを徹底的に頭で考えて体にたたき込んでき
た僕がですねえ伝わるとか感動の部分を
感覚ではなくってしっかりと見える化して皆さんにお伝えしてみた
良いと思いますのでどうぞお楽しみにしていてください
最初にですね僕が実際に伝わったのを感動した体験がありますのでそれをみなさんに
シェアしたいと思います
結婚式の
友人スピーチでの場面です新郎新婦の2人のキューピッド役の男女がスピーチをしたん
ですね
まず女性からスピーチをしました司会者がキューピッド役のない編纂ですというに小脇
呼びますじゃあ女性がですねこうやって等あるんですよ
でも歩いてくるとかかっこいいに座って
daigo さん miki さん今日はご結婚おめでとうございますってね
もう本当にアナウンサーのように話すのうまいなぁ何か話し方の先生かな
この人慣れているんだなというふうに僕自身も思いました
そして最後におめでとうございますって言ってやって帰っていったんですね
綺麗に滑舌もすごい良かったです
拍手やっぱりおめでたいバーですので拍手を貼っておきますえっ
次がすっごい面白かったんです
男性
それではキューピット役のナイナイさんですて歯科医師が言いました
2らゲストの方がその男性のをこうやってみますよね僕もみました
そしたらですね男性がすごく面白かったんです
立った瞬間に顔が真っ青なんですよ
で前に行きますその時てとアシカもこうやって一緒なんです
ってかいはポケットからメモだしました
にも読み始めます
daigo さん3 miki さん
ご結婚
を務めるおめでとうございますってね
ゲストの方がですねジャガーさんわざわざなって大丈夫か見たくなったんですよ
女性からですねガンバレーみたいな声が聞こえてくるんです
街並みやの女性の方弾設定がんばれーって皆の前で言われるとかなり凹むのでちょっと
覚えておいてください
はい情けなくなっちゃうんですよねはいで何でしたっけ
そうこの彼が猫はって
選んだです読めないもぷれちゃって
彼がここで面白い行動と言いました
希少ってたんだよ
でちくしょうちくしょう
池沼って言ってこの紙を音してたんですかっていう
で捨ててその彼は自分の言葉で語り始めました
第5みき俺が俺の企画したあのバーベキューが二人は出会って結婚することになる
なんて俺
思いもしなかったっていう風に言って語り始めたんですねその瞬間みんなシーンとなっ
て彼の言葉を買って聴き始めました
で一番感動したんですねみんな感動したんですけども
僕もこうやってくれてきました一番感動したの新郎
あまりの変わりぷりにコアまでの彼だったんですけども
妙もう熱くしてんスねこうやって真っ赤にして泣きそうになってるんです
そしたらその子の彼がですね
何を言ったか
お前鳴くなんて反則だよって後ろ向いちゃったんだよ買っていっ
ゲストの人がいるように後ろを向いちゃったんです
でもこの背中が語ってるんですよ言葉がないんです
言葉がないのにこの背中が語っているその背中を見て僕も胸が来あって熱くなりました
で彼は振り返って自分の言葉で最後におめでとうって言ってこうして帰っていたさーっ
と逃げるように
その瞬間
もうゲストの方ゲストの人たちも拍手が
うわーっなりました一体となったんですね
つまり彼は感動を本当に前あの全員の感動を巻き込んでいったんです
僕自身も感動し結婚式終わった後にみんなのことは聞こえてきました
あいつ全部一人で持って行っちゃったなというふうに家たんですよ
彼は話すのがうまいかヘタかといったら相当下手くそだと思うんです
センスがあるかないかといったらセンスは相当ないと思うんですね
滑舌が悪いかいい買ったら悪いですでも彼は
ます
自分の言葉で語ることによって会場を感動の頭で巻き込んでいったんですね
皆さん日常でもこういったことあると思います例えばプレゼンテーションの資料
立派な資料を用意してもなんかイマイチ惹かれない人ホワイトボードを使ってこうやっ
て丁寧に汚い字で書くんだけどもグイグイ引き込まれてくる人同じ営業の文章を読んで
も売れるし
売れないしています
服はとか私はこの講座を受けてとかってくれて感情を超えてねこうやって語ることに
よって伝えようとしていても何か引いてしまう人
感情とかこもっていないんだけどもなんかぐいぐい引き込まれてくる人こういう人い
ませんか
なぜこういうことが起きるでしょうかねそれをですね理解するために今日は
3つの意識のスターすっていうのをみなさんにご紹介したいと思いますそれがこちら
です
まず一つ目ですね私たちに意識のスタンス一つ目それが
頭です
頭に意識がいってる時ってのはこういうときです例えば次何しゃべろうか考えている
ときこのメモを買って読んでるだけのとき
分析的なアピールですよねはいそしてもう一つです
もう一つは意識がこの胸に入っている時です
胸に入っているときはこういう時が多いです
緊張している時ドキドキドキドキ緊張している時必死に伝えようとしているとき
頑張って一生懸命なとき言葉に感情を込めようとした時こういった時っていうのは大堤
意識が胸に入ってるんですよね
そしてもう一つ意識の置き所がありますそれがこちらです
原ですね
腹に意識が落とし込まれるとこういったことを置きます
なんかあの人説得力があるよね
learn 母の日と座ってるよねー
何かあっても動じないよね
なんか存在感あるよね
それそれでいて何か自然体
日本では何か一歩深いコミュニケーション
相手とのコミュニケーションそして一歩深い自分自身の思いを相手に届ける時にこの原
というキーワードをたくさん使ってきました例えば腹を割って話す
はらわたが煮えくり返る
腹を決める腹をくくる
腹に落ちる
なぜならばこのハラがぁ自分自身の命を輝かせる危険っていう風に考えてきたからなん
ですね
とにかくプロの舞台の世界ではすべてが腹腹腹でした
ダンスも腹なんです
ダンスやる人は当たり前なんですハラっていうのは例えばですよ
お腹を決めるんです出せる人っていうのはお腹決まっていない人というのはこうなり
ます
体がブレるんですよね
でもダンスやってる人は絶対この腹を決めて ec するんです
ちょっとこうなんです
体がぶれませんよ
ジャンプするときも同じなんです
お腹が決まってないとこうなります
でもお腹を決めることによって
コーってなっていくんですね
普通のこういった踊りとかにしても同じですこの腹を意識するんです
ソースですねほんとにバランスが整っていくんですよねダンスやる人はこの原はも本当
に基本中の基本です
もう腹の移動なんですたーーーーも同じ
でもこれダンスだけではないんです
言葉のニュアンスも全く同じなんですね言葉の意識の置き所です
私たちは言葉発します言葉を発するんですけれどもこの言葉には発する理由っていうの
が必ずあるです
言葉は発しる竜があってそれが一致して初めて言葉になってるんですね
例えばおいしいだったら
美味しいって発生する理由があるから始めて美味しいっていう言葉が出てくるんです
この意識言葉の意識の置き所が
頭にきている場合
あたり頭に落とし込まれている場合はこれは唱えてるって言います
美味しいってこういう感じですよね
はいでこの言葉の意識が畝に来ている場合
多くの人がここでアプローチしをするんです特にこうやって人前に立って何かをやろう
とした時
一生懸命やらなきゃ一生懸命伝えなきゃそして言葉に感情を込めなきゃ
で言葉に感情を込めて伝えようとするんですね例えば
おいしいとかってこういうふうに言葉に感情を込めて伝えようとするんです
これが本人がやった気になるからなんですねでも言葉に感情を込めることが
お金をもらえるかもらえないか言ったら表現の世界ではもらえない方向に行ってしまい
がちです
自分が楽しいか
お客さんが楽しいか言ったら自分が楽しい方向に行ってしまい等なきがちゃんです
見てる人が感動するか感動しないかといったら感動しない方向に行ってしまいがち
ではどうしたらいいかみなさんもうおわかりですよね
はいその言葉言葉を発する理由っていうのを
腹落ちたしていくんです
それがお客さんを喜ばせるということなんですね
これを演劇の世界ではフレージングを磨くって言ったりもします
フレージングを磨くその言葉を発する理由の背景を徹底的に調べて発する理由を腹落ち
さしていくんですね
美味しいで言ったらおいしいって言葉に感情を込めるんではなくてその背景
飲んで感動したんだったら
美味しい
美味しいとかて表現するんじゃなくてその発するリーを腹落ちさして語っていくんです
はいでこのテッドのテーマですね今回フュージョンというのがありました
このフュージョンを考えていますこれを言語化できたりもしているんです
それがこちらでストーン
はい演劇の世界ではフレージングを勝てるって言うんですけどもこれは実感して語ると
いうことに言語化できます
なぜその言葉を発するのかその言葉を発しる理由を演じるのでマク
感情を込めるのではなくただただシンプルにやろうとせずに
その言葉を発する理由を
実感して語っていくんですね例えば僕がへセリフを
あるセリフをもらったとしましょう
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいでって台詞をもらったとします
でこの時にですね例えば頭に意識がいっているとこうなります
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだなんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいでこうなるんですね
これで喜ぶ人いますたとえば子どもの発表会だったらご両親ですね
うちの子が大きくなったこんな舞台に出てセリフや発表会でてるってこうやって嬉しく
なるんですよね
はい
そして多くの方が何かじゃあ人前に立って表現してってなったら
感情を込めて表現しようとするんですねそそこになります
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで
こうなるんですよね
でこれは本人がやった気になるんです
これが伝わると思うんですねここが表現する側と受け取る側の違いの面白いところです
じゃあどうするかさっき言ったとおりですその言葉は発しるりいう背景を徹底的に考え
ていく
本当に妙な本当に不思議な気持ちなんだなんだか胸が締め付けられる
大抵だったら
恋をしたことのない男性が女性を見て雷ドーンて打たれてなんだこれは
胸がドキドキしてくる
なんだろうこの時に息は
不思議な気持ちだっていうところを実感して語っていくんですソースとこうなります
ちょっとやってます
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだなんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいでと違いませんか
こうやってね言葉を一個一個に落とし込んでいくんですミュージカルの歌も同じなん
です
乳児からの歌もなぜその言葉を発するのか
家事の内容を実感して語ります歌っちゃいけないんですよね
だから例えばですねー
歌でなんだか素敵な気持ちラーって言う歌が私ましょう
これをなんだか素敵な気持ちダーってこうやって歌っちゃいけないんですよ
ミュージカル嫌いな人って結構いらっしゃるんですね
嫌いな人
ないですねありがとうございます結構いるんですよ特に男性
なぜかというと急に踊りだす
急に歌い出す
大げさ嘘くさい
これがですねほんとに特に急に歌い出す
これちょっとやってみたいと思います
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで
なんだか素敵な気持ちだ
これがね気持ち悪いんですよ
急に歌い出すんですね
はいでも表現して感動してもらうにはどうしたらいいか
さっき言ったこっから上じゃなくてこっからして何ですちょっとやっています
本当に不思議な気持ちなんだ
なんだか胸が締め付けられるみたいで
なんだか素敵な気持ちだ
て後自然に入るんですよ歌の部分にね
ありがとうございます
だからここから上上辺の表現で雰囲気でやるか
その言葉を一個一個落とし込めているかってよってみてるかが全然違ってくるんですよ
ね
この原落とし込んで腹に落とし込み表現する実感して勝てるって結構怖いです
自分がやった気しないんですよ行ったほうが伝わると思っちゃうので
でもそうではなくてお客さんが
感動する伝わるって言うのは腹に落ちた部分なんですよね
さっきの結婚しの彼もそうですこうして
唱えてました最初はでもチキショーはチキショーッていて泣きそうになったんですけど
そこをグッと抑えてばーんってしてたんですよね
そして自分の言葉で語り始めたんです彼は
滑舌が悪かったかもしれないけどもそこにそのエネルギーがこもっていたんですね
だから聞いている人が
なんか彼の本気の想いというのを感じ取ったっていうわけなんです
絵は舞台の世界だけで
考えられることではないと思います私たちの日常でもこれは通ずることだと思うんです
よね
例えば挨拶です
舞台の世界って挨拶がものすごく厳しいんです
挨拶できない人って生き残れませんなぜかというと
挨拶ってコミュニケーションの基本だからです
言葉を投げますおはようって
そしたら受け取ります受け取って返すんですよね
この言葉のキャッチボールの基本が挨拶なんです
だから普段からおはようございますとか宜しくお願いしますというのを実感して語る
本当の挨拶って言いますこういったの日常から訓練しているんですね
さあいざ舞台に立ったら本当の挨拶とか本当のコザを語れるかといったらそういうこと
できないんです
日常ができていないのに舞台上でできますかって話なんですだから普段挨拶できない子
って舞台上でもやっぱりキャッチボール成立しません
なぜ取ったの投げても受け取ってくれない
受け取ったとしても違う方向に投げちゃいますこれもわかるんですキャッチボールが
できていないっていう風に
なので私たちの普段の挨拶
ございまーすって来て唱えていないか
それとも今日学校に来て会社に来て一時頑張りましょうっていう思いが実感して語れる
かおはようございますよろしくお願いしますというだけでもお互いの目も輝いてくるし
雰囲気も一気に良くなってくると思うんですよね
はいあと例えばお店に入ったときのいらっしゃいませとかもそうだと思います
いらっしゃいませーっていうか
遺書ジェット客を出すかそれとも小さなこう言うかもしれないけども実感して
いらっしゃいませっていうふうに勝たれているを3設定
すごくなんかスタッフ同士の雰囲気もいいですよねまた来たいと思いませんか
例えばお店に入って
いらっしゃいませ
カラー外科ガスからだ今揚げたてですって言うから上げ買いたいと思いますか
本当に捉えるのではなくて
今カラー日浴びたてなんですけどいかがですか美味しいですよっていうふうに言葉を
こうやってプレゼントできたらあ買ってみようかなというふうに思いますよね
そしたらやっぱり消費なんかも上がってくると思いますまた行きたいなというふうに
思うと思うんです
ということで今がですね僕が皆さんにですね
言葉のキャッチボールをやってみたいと思います
こどもミュージカルとか結構出てたんですけども保存は本当にこの上辺化したかってね
わかっちゃうんです
僕がですね
こんにちはっていうふうに言いますたら今日はって返してみてください
はいその時僕本気でいきますのでぜひ本気で返してみてくださいよろしいでしょうか
実感していないしてみてくださいではこっちかいきますでこっちいって最後に皆で行き
ます
いきます
皆さん
こんにちは
21 a
ああ嬉しいですありがとうございます
このような実感して飾るという一歩オフ会コミュニケーションっていうのは自分の元気
ですし相手も元気にすると思いますそれが社会を明るく楽しく元気にすると思います
ぜひ皆さんこれを日常でですね
視点を変えて意識して使ってみてくださいありがとうございました